today's morning rounds two studies
reveal how your diet can have a negative
and long-lasting impact on your health
in new ways
one study found that teenagers extremely
poor eating habits caused him to
effectively go blind the other study
found that people who drank at least two
sugar sweetened soft drinks a day had a
higher risk of death from digestive
diseases and those who drank
artificially sweetened drinks had an
increased risk of death from diseases
that affects the circulatory system and
both groups had an increased risk of
death from Parkinson's disease I mean
this is alarming registered dietitian
Samantha Heller is here with when to
worry and how to break bad habits I mean
this is really surprising thank you for
being here you know I don't think people
realize that they're addicted when
they're drinking soda after soda
everyday how do you break that habit you
know that's a really interesting
question I have had anecdotally many of
my patients tell me they feel addicted
to both non-nutritive sweeteners
artificial sweetened beverages or sodas
I don't know if it's technically an
addiction but how do you stop that
I think by slowly cutting back yeah by
if you drink five sodas a day maybe have
three maybe replacing it if you like
bubbles because this this study also
looked at sugar sweetened beverages not
just sodas but if you like bubbles I'd
rather see a splash of 100% fruit juice
a splash with some seltzer or drinking
seltzer or some herbal infusions you
could have chamomile tea you can have
green tea you can have berry tea ice or
you know water replace it slowly with
things that are healthier for you why
are so why are soda is bad for your
health
you know I think we're looking at an
association not a cause-and-effect and
what we what we have seen through many
studies is that sugar sweetened
beverages like sodas or sugar sweetened
drinks increase the risk for obesity
type 2 diabetes some of these other
diseases but also the artificially Arnon
nutri of sweetened beverages contribute
to certain diseases as well we are not
sure why these they both have citric and
phosphoric acid they can affect your
dental health I rode your tooth enamel
they may be replacing healthier foods in
your diet and if you look at the people
who are consuming them maybe they have a
less healthy lifestyle
there's a lot of parameters that we need
to look at here let's talk about this
picky eating seventeen-year-old I think
this goes beyond picky eating he was
eating fries white bread processed ham
and sausage also Pringles we reached out
to Pringles for comments have not heard
back the kid went effectively blind what
happened here well that's a very rare
scenario and I think the take-home
message sure I think there's two really
important take-home messages one is that
a very poor diet that's high in
processed foods junk food fast food may
increase the risk of nutrient
deficiencies or insufficiencies that
increase the risk for chronic possibly
devastating diseases going blind is very
rare but the second point is when you
have a child who's this picky and this
quote-unquote fussy that they mentioned
in the abstract of the study I would
want to know does he have sensory issues
does he have cognitive or emotional
issues what is it the root of the
problem here are the parents not paying
attention are they trying to pay
attention do they need special help to
find out why this child isn't eating how
do you know when your child's
picky eating habits are actually leading
to this kind of eating disorder I think
you have to be really careful and
observational as you watch your children
if they get picky that's really normal
right that all of a sudden they only
read something pink they only want a
sandwich they only want what their
friends are eating that's really normal
my son ate french fries for five years
but introduce them to healthy foods on a
regular basis have them take part in
helping you make those foods bring them
to the grocery store with you be good
role models always have something on the
plate they like and you may have to
reintroduce a new food 1520 times 30
times and be really patient before your
kid tries it don't force it though I I
don't think forcing is ever a good idea
ya know I can I can tell you that I went
through that with my mom didn't work get
a fun thing make it a family thing say
hey let's go to the grocery store pick
anything you want any produce any of any
vegetable any fruit and we'll see what
we want to do with it we can try having
it in different ways in different ways
of tasting at roasting a puree making a
soup so have it be a fun event sure red
broccoli for dinner come on right now I
eat that now it's just mushrooms I won't
touch it's a psychological thing
Samantha Ellen thank you very much